[Music]
though none of us had your back I had I
miss it you know what I know it's
[ __ ] cheesy I know we're not supposed
to be doing this [ __ ] no more
but i'ma just do it by myself because I
want to indulge me but it's cheesy it's
so cheesy to introduce something like
that mm-hmm
yeah that's true there's something
interesting so Joe yesterday he sent me
this whole thing about like in your
adrenal glands and [ __ ] and the reason
why it
so basically symptomatically speaking
the stuff that he was talking about like
adrenal failure that's what you got is
what I have you know about your CNS
buddy one of the [ __ ] that's very
important is their diet and I can see I
mean a kpop so I clearly listen anything
I read by the way thanks thanks for
bringing these Steve Nikki I did bring
them sweetheart for bringing can you
actually put effort into some of the
stuff that Steve does sometimes because
I really appreciate everything
thank you brother hey thank you hey you
didn't do anything don't take I had to
pass him I had to I had to drive always
messenger does the most work yeah did
you help out all the packaging or with
the sprinkles he actually melted the
plastic and created who do you guys
think do you think the person that
delivers the drugs or the person that
grew it I don't even know the person
that grew it hey when your GrubHub guy
comes do you go hey thanks a lot pal but
thank the guy in the kitchen not [ __ ]
you I didn't mean to thank you or the
one who wrote the song the singer oh
where the singer gets appreciate always
the messenger but you already did a
great job by not forgetting I think you
know that's the hardest part for guys is
I wanna be like don't forget this and as
soon as you hear that I forgot it well I
did forget them but then they made me
she reminded me as I was walking up by
remaining should put it in the passenger
seat she yelled at it filled it out yeah
but yeah did you guys see that
Casey Neistat video where he interviewed
Robert No
interviewed who he the the see the
business officer of YouTube he's in
charge of all the creation Oh what was
that like did he did he grow disaster
was he like hey I love you you know what
it was it was it was not that great it
was he's like nothing is off-limits it
was supposed to be like straight-up raw
but then he's like huh so boxers are
brief and it's like you know dude how
about you ask about those YouTube [ __ ] I
think he was asking really good
questions but it was just the response I
mean he can't it's really safe that's a
good question uh he was asking things
like oh what's your response as to how
now the fact that YouTube requires like
a certain amount of subscribers or views
like for smaller YouTube channels to get
monetization like how did which respond
to that he was just like yeah well you
know as long as the creators are
successful YouTube successful too and it
was just really like the most PC bland
yeah but it was a it was a I would say
it was a step up from nothing because
some of the some of the things were
answered right and all okay cool but
Casey also didn't like pursue the
question further but he's not a journal
exactly he's not a journal that's not he
sells something to CNN I think he's
trying to be a journalist in my own mind
I feel being be saw being is apt to CNN
for X amount of gajillion dollars for 25
mil or something it was like something
ridiculous it was like a big-ass [ __ ]
number but that I actually got absorbed
into CNN and it didn't exist separately
anymore and that it failed or so he was
a tax write-off for seeing it you know
what they give me a sense of relief
though is when he was talking about how
both sides whether its advertisers or
their creators they both feel that
YouTube is on the other person's side so
the advertisers like why are you and on
the creator side and we feel like why
are you on the [ __ ] advertiser side
well I was how are youtubers is sucking
advertisers dick all the time that's how
we feel right and I was like okay but
the points that he made it made a lot of
sense like they just I love the honesty
behind it because he just couldn't
compute he was honest about not being
able to control it all he didn't know
what to do every day they're panicking
trying to figure it out
my [ __ ] both of my words don't work
my words might make sure everyone in the
office yeah yeah mister you know what
the answer is
this is what I think that honest answers
is probably the easiest thing to do in
the world I don't know why they'd never
do this I think YouTube and all their
[ __ ] circle jerk buddies they keep
looking within for answers that's right
but none of them are advertisers and
none of them are content creators
they've never made a video they've never
they've never gotten the problem never
you did a brand do a video or built an
audience like TV like exactly they did a
focus group and they brought in some
youtubers and actually pick their brain
they do that I went to one and it was
garbage because what's the ones who
actually was perfect all they do is they
think it's like you're talking to a call
center for like you have a computer
problem and you're talking to a call
center and the and the guy the call
center can only read off of a sheet they
can't answer your questions but that's
how what I meant was like so we did the
focus thing right the focus routine like
if the backhauls of VidCon where they do
that and they have like this list of
like the script of what they're supposed
to ask you and then everything is like
okay on a scale of 1 through 5 is the
[ __ ] I want to explain myself
instead of just giving these really
controlled responses but instead of
doing that what they need to do is
actually hire some youtubers as a
consultant so whatever you're paying
like some whatever producer or
programming director 100 grand a year
pay youtuber to help you develop that
whole side of things for 100 grand a
year and I can get a youtuber like a
real one real like what they always do
this is so funny man because I know so
many people who kind of washed out right
they did never really made it on YouTube
yeah and then they they always washed
out in the same places and it's always
like they're now the they're now the
consultants or social media [ __ ] you
know what was a popcorn company or
something and it's like or Xbox and it's
like wait how the [ __ ] did you get this
job you couldn't even build an audience
on your own that's true
they talk a good game they talk to you
you don't know that did you say that
that person that saw this is probably
crying right
crying with [ __ ] hundred-dollar bills
do it yeah it's like come on man they
get one of their personal change ask
people for help if you need help that's
well they don't but this is not how they
do it right like they do it the
corporate command structure is like hey
if somebody has a degree we're gonna
listen to they have a degree in
communications of course they know how
to reach an audience of whatever the
[ __ ] people in as many years that HBR
whatever right they think like it's got
to be a puzzle piece that fits into the
missing piece of the puzzle like not
like something creative like we are
entrepreneurs so two entrepreneurs they
act differently we look at skills and
what have you made and what have you
done and what have you done for yourself
versus people in a corporate structure
it's what's your resume what jobs have
you had
what's your you know they look at that
as legitimacy so when they see us and
they even if we're making millions of
dollars doesn't make it doesn't matter
they do they see it as like oh you're
just a one-trick pony you're your one
hit single you're nice whatever yeah and
then they see artists that are business
savvy and they make money but they don't
see us as entrepreneurs and that's the
issue on that panel because I would ask
some serious questions I would ask them
you know what's weird I always wanted to
ask advertisers this it's like why I'll
come they only promote the white
youtubers that - why do you care who
sees your product as long as somebody
buys it you know what I mean so as for
example they're like they don't want
whatever like gangbang violence type of
videos to show up and pampers to be on
there just cuz you punch somebody in the
face doesn't mean you don't put your
babies in people want that don't want a
specific demographic deviation you know
yeah I guess but see that's a common
thing everybody that's done matters you
know it's just the dumbest [ __ ] thing
to me on earth it's like well this video
has but well violent people also have
children most though their kids also use
diapers you know and they also shop at
Target well I also love though they
always do this [ __ ] words like you're
watching some video with somebody who
just filled their whole room full of
bouncy balls right and before it you see
an ad for [ __ ] Acura and I'm like
wait wait wait okay hold on so people
who are going out looking for a video
where a bunch of kids are throwing
bouncy balls and filling a whole room
with bouncy balls are looking for
accurate
obviously something got [ __ ] up by the
average instead absurd as the fight with
the Pampers theme exactly a third really
is correlation so it's just view account
and advertising and they just leave it
that way what I don't like is the
inconsistency because when the whole I
think it was ice or a terrorist incident
happened well I think it was in France
or something like that right during that
time they were d monetizing videos and
everyone that had like just France in
general yeah and you know during that
time people were like hey what's the
what's the big deal why won't you let me
you know post this video and and in
their responses we don't want our brand
to be associated with this type of event
and then they got a screenshot of CNN TV
like just commercials and ads running
through the whole same thing and it's
like their time it's the same brand you
know like it is kind of like how is that
even consistent and they did it again
for the Las Vegas shooting so it was
pretty big I think it was Casey Neistat
or one of the big guys they did a video
to get I guess like some kind of charity
or something for this event and they s
they block the video or something
happened and people also showed that
like yeah on regular television they
were running commercials running the
same things and it's like if you don't
want to be associated with this event
and this content why did you let this
happen like why they were monetizing on
I mean there's stuff you tube CNN or
whatever yeah but it's because that's
the part of the plan right like when you
watch TV you expect commercials so they
don't they don't ever look to take that
out it was pre rolls for a YouTube
channel like YouTube CNN YouTube knew
yeah and then in it they were they were
doing it on there but they weren't
letting Casey nice that or other buddy
yeah
thing - yeah like the fact what do they
say you know the most recent controversy
like he has now is like him tasering a
dead rat I heard about it I didn't watch
it it was already dead
yeah you're just like teenager or these
rats and so that just took it for what's
wrong with that
but I think I think maybe the fact that
he's already like taking suicide so
lightly and now he's doing this to
something that was living it's like bad
timing bra like you're [ __ ]
insensitive and you're [ __ ]
psychopath I think it's just weird oh
wow they were okay with making fun of
suicide there's no need to touch the
furry creature no I think it's the the
the D monetizing his channel was a
response a fight like finally they they
figured out I mean I appreciated that I
think they should just delete this
channel though like because a piece of
[ __ ] although all youtubers got their
channels will be a slippery slope dude I
was in the actually am YouTube meeting
at Google where they were talking about
similar [ __ ] I remember a bunch of
there's a bunch of there's a couple sjw
people in the room and then it was like
me and then it was I remember the fine
brothers were there and we were all it
was basically like a free speech form or
whatever like hey what's considered okay
speech on YouTube and I was like
anything and then people are like whoa I
don't think it's okay if like somebody
somebody came to my channel to give me a
death threat is that free speech Steve
and I was like look I don't I don't
think people should be able to advocate
violence that's obviously illegal right
you can't just say like hey I want to
kill you but but the but but then they
were like well what if somebody you know
people always bully me on my channel I'm
like okay well I mean this part of doing
videos on YouTube right is that people
are gonna say like hey a shitty thing to
you yeah that's just that's for you to
deal with welcome you could block them
you can do whatever you you have to do
but the idea that YouTube has to
facilitate that I think is creates an
infrastructure for them where they have
to like hands on like make sure nobody's
saying bad things I think it's
impossible traditional media's not even
like that because you have you know you
have TMZ's and you had like the tabloids
like I think that's just kind of the
nature of being an entertainment you're
susceptible to people's opinion like art
that's it if you're an artist to any
degree you're kind of susceptible to
someone's opinion and if you don't like
their opinion though should the channel
be deleted because that's that's what I
get I get weird I don't want anyone's
channel a beetle yeah I think it's like
the the channel deletion thing the only
reason why I say he should is because
people have gotten their channels to
leave it for ten times less so it's like
if you're gonna delete their channels
[ __ ] to leave his - I get it you know
what I mean so it's just like that that
it's so unfair you know I mean like it's
like like Tim Tim got his channel
deleted right three times do you guys
what yeah it's insane that point yet
Timothy DeLaGhetto
- right yeah so [ __ ] like that happens
you know I didn't mean and so it's kind
of like that favoritism is really
obnoxious to me you know and the other
reason why well they're gonna protect
their assets because at the end of the
day it's a business and you know like in
in the whole conversation you was
talking about how there's hundreds of
people that rely on Logan Paul for work
like people that it's a hard decision to
make on the spot because there's exactly
you're one of them but is that even like
that's is that YouTube's consideration
like I don't think it should be
YouTube's consideration if Logan Paul
LLC and whoever he's employing in his
mom's retirement I don't think that
should be YouTube's consideration
YouTube only has a relationship directly
with Logan pop well it's you direct me
and my finning sequel to bad but I feel
like big corporations kind of do that
too you know like people like Bill each
other out so let's say it's for example
if jakey got into a mess if I was like
hey you know what like Isaac really
needs those pair of cargo pants I don't
think you could just let us call right
now they're gonna give a [ __ ] you know
what I mean I think that why does he
need the cargo get big enough they will
give a [ __ ] yeah with with with you know
views and influence there's power and of
course he's gonna get special treatment
it's just that we're not there yet so
we're not gonna get special treatment
but once we are there we're gonna want
that huh yeah so would you say we're
some very salty I'm hella salty yes so
it is kind of a huge bummer that Logan
Paul kind of put this like damper on the
whole YouTube thing but one dope thing
that I'm looking forward today I'm gonna
do with you guys is the whole playlist
live thing and I don't know if I were to
see Logan Paul there I feel
I'd be like yeah let's yeah let's say
let's say you're uh
I don't even better play the slide I
would you know let's say there's this
crowd right yeah and you always know you
tuber when you see what I get there's
like there's like a huge VidCon he has a
huge party around and then you are you
guys need to take a piss and for some
reason you guys me yeah you and your
noggin pause oh you guys go to the
bathroom and for some unisex bathrooms
obviously and it's just you - yeah in
the sink washing hands oh [ __ ] this
let me just real quick he doesn't wash
his hands
so this week get to the point what's the
point
it's you and Logan power using the same
sleep what are you gonna do I would know
what's wrong I know what's right he's
not gonna show up now yeah no that's
exactly what I do well I'm watching
hands I'll be like yo can I get a
picture
you're fine saw bin Laden if I saw bin
Laden I'd be like that's what that was
he would feel it that's that's the type
of comment that sticks with you all day
because you're like wait what did I do
so you're like thinking about I get some
psychological so you would wonder what
it is in psychological [ __ ] you know
what you know what will really [ __ ] up a
youtuber like him though if he comes up
to you because obviously yeah I guess
you're attractive and so he'll probably
come up to you and say something right
and then you go I'm sorry who are you
somebody like that was such a big you
know something like that kind of
happened to me in the beginnings of the
youtubes yeah when I told you about it
no I'm saying it happened a lot because
when I first came to LA number one I
don't know what the [ __ ] YouTube was and
I remember I'm not we're friends now but
he was like oh yeah I represent KevJumba
like who's that because I represent
josephus and I was like who's that [ __ ]
me all the time cuz I don't want you to
because it hurts my brain
like I really honestly don't I don't
want you watch our stuff though I do i
watch our stuff yeah but I don't but I
don't watch like YouTube YouTube right
like I'm a person now and you have that
I don't watch it and that's not for any
other reason than I don't want to
accidentally take on somebody else's
thoughts or the way they talk or
anything like that and I find that if
you watch them long enough and you start
to start to eat their patterns and stuff
and I don't want to do anything cuz even
like the Paul's they became apparent in
my role when they were just so
everywhere then there was like oh who
are these guys you know I mean but prior
to that people are saying I was dumb
because I don't know who the [ __ ] they
were but that's me everywhere cuz I go I
go places all the time and I don't know
if people are youtubers and they always
introduce themselves or whatever we're
supposed to do then and I'm supposed to
know man I don't [ __ ] know how do
they do they like hi nice to meet you
no no I can't see anyone there's not
gonna poach to it you know they may say
Oh Bubba I'm yeah right
oh hey I'm uh whatever the [ __ ] first
name alright no idea you are swear to
God mind just doing this thing together
power my story uh what happened to me
was so it was this big youtuber at the
time he was maybe top five so then I
read this event together and that was
with JK and then he was like two rows
like in front of us so then I saw that
he dropped his phone so I'm like oh hey
excuse me because I didn't know him we
didn't we had no rapport oh I'm like oh
hey excuse me but it was kind of odd I'm
like you dropped your phone he was oh hi
you want a picture and I was like no you
just dropped your phone I know who this
is no you don't yeah I do
was it raywilliamjohnson know exactly
who's that guy he was automatic like
that cuz he was socially exactly they're
all socially it's like no house gonna
make a joke I was like well how far did
he have to reach to reach the phone yeah
I was gonna figure out who he was when
he had to have his brother hold his feet
yeah
no but I used to work with that cat like
I worked with like everybody then but
but yeah ray is that beef oh it's not
like a good beef thing it's like um
just chicken ya know a little bit of
ticket there you go taking it a food
land what's the love chicken papa good
yeah I don't I don't I don't
particularly like the guy but and I
worked with him for a long time the only
because he was such a douche the whole
time but the guy would like one time I'm
sitting in I'm sitting in the writers
room right and he comes in he's like all
like like oldest [ __ ] and I'm like yeah
what's going on right come on and and he
cuz I could tell he wanted to get ready
but I could tell anyone anything get it
off his chest for her he's like no he's
he's looking around he's like oh yeah
this kind of [ __ ] so he's like there's
this awards show in like [ __ ] Iceland
or whatever he's like and um they want
to give me like two hundred thousand
dollars to come present an award at
their award show he's like but it's on
18-hour flight and I was like are you
[ __ ] absolutely I'm getting this [ __ ]
humble but [ __ ] money to be here exactly
he just wanted to brag about how they
wanted to give him that much and how
even better than that he didn't think he
was gonna do it because the flight I
don't even have a thought like that in
my head it's like hey can you come to
Iceland for two I'm there
yes I mean by like it's like do I have a
beef with the guys like not a beef it's
like it's like I love 18-hour flight
especially if it's him he's probably
going for it I love $200,000 how about
that
yeah I like Iceland I do it for just
Iceland I'll go to Antarctica for two
energy drink bloody what for to go
anywhere just give me the flight just 18
hours back - exactly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]